all the symbolism that is around
him you are The kingpin of the cables close
silence you did not move you are the
skin of Judas get ready
and the program was that they were going to talk to
the pope you are boring to start talking
madly you
ball to the center start the  party
you have
payroll if I were not a feminist I would be a
better Christian the issue of pedophilia
in the church I
was a very believing Catholic I am no longer a
Catholic but I get the feeling at
least from what you see around me that
people are disappointed with the church
no  With God,
all this does not generate a contradiction.
Coherence is what
Christians find most difficult. I would like
to ask you if you are
happy and if you have ever felt alone,
abortion exists
in the church, not as an institution, and I have
never known  I am
going to give
that life a chance, I
learned a lot from you, it did me
a lot of good and I thank you for the good you
have done to me
[Music]